ça nous a inspirés de séquences enfin
après on va dire j'imite mal mais je
m'en fous c'est un principe toute façon
quand ils vont faire un truc assez moyen
voire mid onemedia non mais ça il peut y
avoir quelque chose alors j'ai pas il ya
peu de répétitions des a donc déjà
commencé mais en plus je sens pas je
sens pas là ils vont tous faire une
imitation
ouais n'hésitez pas à faire un petit
commentaire quoi nous interrompre n'ont
pas forcément parce que quand c'est
ridicule c'est drôle mais quand c'est
drôle ça ma wii comment ça va les
divines
alors ça fait six ans les 3 4 et venez
d'avoir pardon mais celle que les
paroles de la chanson ont tous aimé
l'homme mais quand on fait des
limitations en fait malheureusement on
imite l'imitateur wii sera fait on
baisse un peu engageant
c'est pas mal je sais pas mais on a tout
vu alors oui mais bon soir benjamin
castaldi à fanny ardant c'est vrai ah
oui je ne sais pas faire trop les femmes
vous en la non non non non non non je
fais surtout les garçons aussi grave
chacun songe ouverte qu'on aime on sait
jamais si ce qu'il restait quand même
vous devez rester qu'on aime quoi faire
avec maxime gainey
et bien vous allez faire pom pom girls
ce week-end ou quoi j'ai mis un petit
bond une petite veste décontractés
on s'approche du week-end donc il faut
être dans l'air du temps je savais qu'il
fallait pas que je pose en apposant je
savais que ça allait et l'appui comme à
chaque fois alors dans la série désastre
qui feint allez-y faites votre vitesse
alors qu'ils d'incarnation d'imitation
regarder suffit de m aïe aïe aïe le
bandana musique et il est banni
[Musique]
c'est ce système que d'une galette avec
les limitations seyssois l'accent belle
matinée d'un peu de suisses à zahlé
surpris et il a répété
elle a beaucoup répété oui jour faire
cette imitation besoin de mon un stream
plaisir de la petite marie je parle de
toi
ses petites manies petit mari c'est
parfois on ne fait pas confiance on a
connu la chanson mais pas son auteur
mais jamais pour tanger
vous avez reconnu comme je le dit et il
a dit à ses causes oubliées déjà on soir
mecheri a c'est bientôt la chaux vive
renault l'édredon
[Applaudissements]
je vais demander à la fin de la séquence
à didier de nous donner la meilleure
imitation l'eau pour l'instant one eye
et même un positionnement de la main
était juste ouais nan mais franchement
un soutien c'est un bug la meilleure et
la pire à l'améliorer labellisation un
peu âgées limite malville m'en fous et
votre invitation
non mais alors oui nous avons vidé des
sens très bien
pour l'instant on est d'accord magali
[Applaudissements]
alors magali a de multiples talents oui
mais il y en a 1 qu'elle n'a pas assez
les mutations
la preuve salut mes fans si j'espère que
ça va vous allez me regarder ce soir sur
mon prime time parce que je vous attends
mon endroit mutation est basse mais le
texte est excellent limite mal mais je
m'en fous on y va à l'essai oui or la
joe dassin hypothèses soit terminé
pas mal prochain alors didier qui sont
l'héritage aux biens bah on va tâcher il
selon vous le meilleur signé le meilleur
david je pense david habib
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]